الرئاسه الروسيه المانيا تطلق النار على
ساقها وبوتين يغلق سماعه هاتفه في وجه
تشيلسي
واشنطن تصافح الايادي الروسيه من خلف
الستار الاوكراني
العجب والنات يحطم امال
الاوكرانيينسكي يرفض الهديه الافريقيه
والرئيس تبون للغرب الجزائري
ون حرارا وسيبقون احرارا والفرقه الروسيه
الضخمه تدخل دوله عربيه والاتحاد الاوروبي
يبدا معركه النفس الطويل ضد الولايات
المتحده وبعد يوم من اطلاق الصواريخ
الباليستيه كم يجتمع بقاده بلاده وامريكا
تحرك اسلحتها النوويه نحو كوريا
افريقيا تقول كلمتها وبوتين يرحب
وبعد ان وضعت افريقيا اوراقها امام اطراف
الحرب الاوكرانيه افريقيا تكشف اوراقها
لياتي الدور على اطراف النزاع للاختيار
هنا وفد افريقي بقياده رئيس جنوب افريقيا
ورئيس السنغال ورئيس الوزراء المصري ينطلق
في رحلته ليلتقي الوفد ثم ذهب نحو موسكو
ليلتقي ببوتين لوضع مبادره النقاط العشر
فباشرهم الرئيس الاوكراني
برفضه اجراء محادثات سلام مع روسيا قبل ان
تسحب قواتها من الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي
سيطرت عليها وقال ان اي محادثات مع موسكو
في الوقت الراهن تعني تجميد الحرب اما في
موسكو فاستقبل الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين وتباحث معهم في مبادراتهم للتسويه
في اوكرانيا ليسرح بوتين بان بلاده منفتحه
على الحوار مع كل من يرغب في السلام مع
مراعاه مصالح جميع الاطراف ليشكر بوتين
الموقف الافريقي المتوازن حيال الازمه
الاوكرانيه لكن بعد رفض زيلينسكي هل سيدفن
الافارقه هنا مفتاح الصلح ليؤكد رئيس
السنغال ان ميثاق منظمه الامم المتحده
اساس للحوار بين روسيا واوكرانيا معربا عن
ثقته بالتزام روسيا به بصفتها بلدا مؤسسا
للمنظمه وعضوا دائما في مجلس الامن وبعد
التصريحات الالمانيه برفض بوتين اتصالا
هاتفيا من المستشار الالماني
خرج المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
لم يتلقى اي مقترحات لاجراء محادثات
هاتفيه بين الرئيس بوتين وماكرون
انه للاسف فقد قررت المانيا ان تطلق النار
على ساقها باتباعها المسار الامريكي وعلى
ما يبدو فانها تتبع النهجه الامريكي لتكون
عضوا مثاليا في النيتو والذي بالطبع ينفذ
جميع التعليمات من واشنطن لان الناتو
بقياده امريكا ولا توجد قياده جماعيه هناك
وفق قوله فما هو ردكم يا احفاد هتلر بينما
احبط الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن معنويات
الاوكرانيين وذلك بتاكيد انه لكي تنضم
ك عليها نفس المتطلبات التي حققها الاعضاء
الاخرون في الحلم وان واشنطن لن تجعل هذا
الطريق اسهل عليك وهذا ما يعني اشتراكها
في انهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا يا ساده وهذا
امر ليس بيدك بعد اليوم
لتنتقل بنا الاحداث نحو المعارك الدائره
في اوكرانيا قليله حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان قواتها وجهت الليله الماضيه
ضربه باسلحه عاليه الدقه بعيده المدى تطلق
من الجو والبحر على احد مراكز صنع القرار
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه لتضيف الوزاره
ايضا مقتل 600 عسكري اوكرانيا في يوم واحد
خلال محاولات للهجوم في ثلاثه اتجاهات
مهلا مهلا مهلا ما كل هذه الارقام الفلكيه
اليكم المصدر قصفت المقاتلات الروسيه
بالصواريخ موقعين لتجمع القوات الاوكرانيه
في مدينه اكراماتورسك اثرت عن مقتل اكثر
من 600 قاتل اوكراني بحسب وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
لتضيف انها قدمت مكافات اضافيه لقواتها
التي دمرت دبابات ليوبارد الالمانيه
وعربات المصفحه امريكيه في اوكرانيا وليس
ذلك فحسب حيث اضافت الدفاع الروسيه انها
احبطت خمس هجمات اوكرانيه على محور مردفه
ان الاوكرانيين خسائر كبيره خلالها
هجماتهم على محور دوناتس وبدورها قالت
سلطات دونت مواليه لروسيا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول اختراق الدفاعات في محيط
مدينه وعرقله تقدم الوحدات الروسيه بحسب
وكاله سبورتناك على الطرف الاخر اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني يقتحم مواقع للقوات
الروسيه قرب ضخمه والسيطره عليها فيما
اعلن سلاح الجو الاوكراني انه تمكن من
اسقاط 12 صاروخا روسيا منها سته صواريخ
كنيغال فرط صوتيه خلال ساعات قليله وبما
ان امريكا بنفسها كانت قد اعترفت بانها
غير قادره على اسقاط صواريخ كاريجان فكيف
تمكنت كييف من اسقاطها نشاهد المصدر اعلن
مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان الدفاعات الاوكرانيه
اسقطت 12 صاروخا روسيا من نوع كنجال
وطائرتين مسيرتين ليسرح وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ان روسيا سنه القصف الاعنف على
كييف منذ اسابيع وهناك قال قاده بالجيش
الاوكراني ان قواتهم تتقدم في القطاعات
الجنوبيه في اطار هجومها المضاد ضد القوات
الروسيه ليحين الدور على الرئيس الاوكراني
والذي قال كل كل خطوه جديده نتخذها كل شبر
يحرر من الاراضي الاوكرانيه له اهميه قصوى
بينما كان محافظ مقاطعه
قد اعلن ان الجيش الاوكراني اطلق اكثر من
180 قذيفه من عيارات مختلفه على المراكز
السكنيه في المقاطعه الليله الماضيه ومن
الحرب الاوكرانيه الى المعضله الامريكيه
للطاقه حيث ذكرت صحيفه نيويورك ان شركه
الطاقه النوويه الامريكيه لا تزال تعتمد
على اليورانيوم المخصب الرخيص المصنوع في
روسيا حتى ان واشنطن تدفع المليارات
للوكاله النوويه الروسيه موضحه ان هذه
المعضله الجيوسياسيه تتفاقم خاصه ان تغير
المناخي يؤكد الحاجه الى طاقه خاليه من
الانبعاثات ومن امريكا الى مصر حيث ظهرت
فرقه الاسطول الشمالي الروسي
الادميرالوشوب في ميناء الاسكندريه بمصر
خلال زياره قامت بها في الفطره من 12 الى
من يونيو حزيران الجاري واظهر طاقم
السفينه اثناء تنفيذ مهمه التدريب تنسيقا
عاليا للاجراءات وفقا لوسائل الاعلام
الروسيه وبين هذا وذاك وخلال زيارته
لروسيا قال الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد
تبون ردا على سؤال بشان ضغوط غربيه على
الجزائر لوقف اقتناء السلاح من روسيا
الجزائريون ولدوا احرارا وسيبقون احرارا
وكما اخبرناكم سابقا فابناء عبد المجيد
تبون لا يلعبون
الاحداث والتطورات
بعد يوم من اطلاق كوريا الشماليه لصاروخين
باليستيين نحو مياهها الشرقيه وهو الرد
الحتمي الذي هدد به كم بسبب التدريبات
العسكريه التي اجرتها القوات الكوريه
الجنوبيه والامريكيه في المنطقه في وقت
سابق لتعلن بيونج يانغ ان حزب العمال
الكوريين الحاكم بدا اجتماعا مهما لتحديد
استراتيجيه البلاد في ظل الوضع الدولي
المتغير وذلك بحضور الزعيم كيم جونغ اون
فما الذي يخطط له كام لياتي الرد الامريكي
حيث قال الجيش الكوري الجنوبي ان غواصه
امريكيه تعمل بالطاقه النوويه وصلت الى
ميناء في مدينه بوسان في كوريا الجنوبيه
ولاول مره منذ ما يقرب ست سنوات التي
تتوقف فيها غواصه تعمل بصواريخ كروز في
كوريا الجنوبيه ذكرت مصادر غربيه ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يسعى الى تقليل الاعتماد
على السلاح الامريكي خلال الفتره المقبله
ياتي ذلك في وقت تحث فيه الولايات المتحده
الدول الاوروبيه على زياده الانفاق
الدفاعي وشراء الاسلحه الامريكيه من خلال
التعاقد مع الشركات امريكيه قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
انه سيتوجه الاسبوع المقبل الى الصين
لتجنب ما وصفه بالحسابات الخاطئه مع بيكين
واضاف ان زيارته تهدف الى اقامه اتصالات
مفتوحه وقويه مع الصين اعلنت قوات الدعم
السريع في السودان قبولها باي اتفاق يقود
لمشروع هدنه جديده متى ما شاهدت جديه
الطرف الاخر في اشاره للجيش السوداني
القاره السمراء تتدخل لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه فقبل بوتين ورفض زيلينسكي
برايكم هل انتهت بذلك مبادره الا فارقه
دون اي فائده
[موسيقى]